welcome to the man of Recaps this is you
seasons one through three meet Joe
Goldberg a nice normal guy who manages a
bookstore but one day his life changes
when a woman walks in and he has a meat
cute with gwenevere Beck Joe is
instantly smitten in fact his inner
monologue changes talking to Beck hello
you which gives the show its name now
like any reasonable modern dater Joe
immediately starts stalking her social
media but he goes a step further and
starts stalking her offline oh yeah nah
he's a creeper but Joe's not a bad guy
who wants to hurt her or anything and we
get his inner monologue where he's
convinced himself this is all very
reasonable so much like Dexter from back
in the day Joe is an anti-hero we can
kind of root for and the tone of this
show is not the psycho thriller Joe's
stalking problem is more of a dark
comedy so Gwen of your back is trying to
be a writer but she spends a lot of time
partying with her friends and one night
drunkenly taking the train home oh no
she falls and Joe's gotta save her they
have a second to meet cute oh yeah I
hear the girl from the bookstore what a
coincidence only in New York right and
so their love story is off to a great
start but there's immediately a problem
Beck's current kind of boyfriend Benji
he's a douchey trust fund hipster who
doesn't really respect Beck so Jose was
like oh Becca I gotta save you from him
he lures Benji into a dark hallway and
oh hits him with the hammer okay so Joe
does kill people except he's really bad
at killing people Benji survives but now
Joe's got him locked in a cage why does
Joe have a creepy glass cage well it's
in the bookstore it's to preserve rare
books but as Joe found out when he was a
kid taken in by the bookstore owner it
also is a great place to lock people up
so Joe uses his social media skills to
make it look like Benji's on a bender
and Beck's ready to cut him out of her
life and with him out of the picture Joe
and Beck can resume their magical New
York love story now Joe is convinced
he's a good person he doesn't want to
kill Benji but pretty soon he realizes
he can't let him out without going to
jail and so he kills him so now he's
officially murdered someone but he's
like hey this was a good thing I did it
to save you back and that's really the
essence of Joe's whole thing he's got
that white knight syndrome wants to save
Beck from all the problems in her life
and for a while things are wonderful as
Joe and Beck are madly in love but soon
there's a new obstacle Beck's best
friend Peach Salinger who doesn't like
Joe and is overly possessive back so Joe
puts back on his classic stalker
baseball cap to investigate Peach and
after stealing her laptop he finds out
she is also obsessively in love with
Beck Joe needs a plan to get Peach out
of the picture but he's not the criminal
mastermind he just hits her in the head
with a rock and he continues to be
terrible at killing people she's totally
fine and now Beck's just spending more
time with her to nurse her back to
health so Joe follows them to Peach's
parents country house where Peach is
talking back while Joe is stalking peach
talking back but after Becca goes home
Peach discovers Joe and after a scuffle
he kills her too with all the reading
he's done Joe is very good at writing
believable suicide notes in other
people's voices but again not to
criminal mastermind while he was hiding
he peed in the jar and left it there a
piece of physical evidence that the pi
Peach's parents hired may or may not
ever find and so for a while things are
really good again but soon Joe has bad
dreams he's being haunted by his
ex-girlfriend Candace Candace has come
up a few times the story is she cheated
on Joe and broke his heart and ran off
with a boyfriend to Italy but now we get
to see they were in love and Joby came
overly possessive and when he stalked
them found out she was cheating he
pushed this guy off the roof and it sure
looks like he killed Candace too and now
it's happening again he suspects Beck is
cheating on him with her therapist Dr
Nikki but unlike Candace Beck comes
clean yes I was but I broke it off
because I love you Joe and these two can
live happily ever after except by chance
Beck finds Joe's secret hidey hole with
all his stalker stuff including evidence
that links in him to the murder of Benji
and Peach and before she can flee Joe
knows that she knows somehow Beck's the
one locked in the book cage he's like
Beck I'm so sorry I would never hurt you
everything I've done has been to help
you I just got to keep you locked in
here until you cool down and realize
that which of course is never going to
happen after a while with nothing else
to do Beck starts writing in fact she
writes the story of her and Joe but she
changes the ending so that it's her
jilted lover Dr Nikki who killed her
friends and kidnapped her and she's like
look Joe I love you this will be our
story you can let me out and we can live
happily ever after so Joe lets her out
but of course she was lying and tries to
escape unfortunately there's another
cage upstairs and Joe always keeps a
spare key Inside the Cage just in case
and SoJO realizes Beck is not his true
love after all and he does murder her so
yeah kind of a bad guy that story was a
good one and with the planted evidence
Dr Nikki goes to jail and in fact Joe
getzbeck's book published posthumously
and it's a huge hit so even after
murdering her he's like well Beck you're
welcome now almost immediately a new
woman walks in hello you but it's not a
new you it's an old you it is Candice
yeah she's alive she tracked him here
and that's where season one comes to an
end so in season two we see that Joe did
indeed kidnap Candace and when she tried
to run he accidentally killed her but
he's really bad at killing people she
was totally fine went to the cops but
with no physical evidence there was
nothing to do but pretend to be dead but
when she read Beck's book she knows it
was Joe who did it again and now she's
here to hang big threats of exposure
over his head so Joe gets up to go to
the bathroom and he goes all the way to
Los Angeles where he hopes Candace can't
find him he gets a job at the organic
Supermarket a navrid managing the little
book section there and though he's
promised himself he's gonna stop
stalking almost immediately he spots a
new girl hello you her name is Love
she's the food supervisor here and she
and Joe have a meat cute and she's real
into Joe asks him on a date for a taco
tour of La it's a magical evening and
these two are off to a whirlwind romance
without Joe stalking her except we find
out he actually met her earlier and
that's why he got the job there in the
apartment where he can stalk her so old
habits die hard now Joe's actually going
by a fake name this season will
betelheim which is the fake identity of
the guy who was gonna sell him a fake
identity and so the first thing Joe did
when he got to La was rent a storage
unit and build a plastic book cage in
there but Joe really wants to be a
better person this season so he's like
hey man I'm gonna let you out and and
trust that you won't go to the cops and
because this guy's a criminal too it
actually works he goes to the
Philippines with his girlfriend and
these do become friends so his things
with love are generally going good Joe
gets wrapped up in a major subplot with
his building manager Delilah who has a
precocious younger sister Ellie Who
Wants To Be A filmmaker she's landed an
internship with this comedian Henderson
and hendy seems like a good guy but he
and Delilah have some history she can't
prove it but when she was a teenager
handy roofie then sexually assaulted her
SoJO wants to protect Ellie uses
stalking powers for good and indeed one
night tandy's gonna drug her but luckily
Joe's there to drug him too Joe doesn't
want to kill him he just wants him to
confess but turns out Joe is really good
at killing people when he's trying not
to and once again Joe is not to criminal
mastermind but they do rule hendy's
death a suicide now Love's parents
actually own a novren and her twin
brother 40 he also kind of works here
he's a classic La douche who thinks he's
a screenwriter because he had one almost
hit but really he's just a Hollywood
adjacent party boy he is sober these
days except when he's not and Joe's got
to babysit him a bunch because love
loves him pretty soon Joe gets to meet
Love's parents who turns out are kind of
awful people but this brings Joe and
love closer together they come up with
their cute couple phrase I wolf you 40
has brought his new girlfriend to meet
the parents too but turns out it is
Candice this she found Joe and is here
under a fake name to loom the threat of
exposure over him so Joe puts on his
stalker cap to take care of Candace but
turns out love has it covered because
she's rich and the Queens have pis on
retainer When Love exposes Candace she
tries to tell her that she was a stalker
killer but love doesn't want to hear it
she does discover though that Jill lied
about his identity he tells the partial
truth I was running for my crazy
ex-girlfriend but she's like I'm mad you
lied to me we break up to make Joe
jealous love immediately rebounds with a
hot Australian and Joe joins in and
starts banging his neighbor Delilah but
even after hendy's death she's still
trying to expose him and when she finds
out Joe was in his house she does some
snooping she finds his secret creepy
clear cage with Andy's laptop in it just
then Joe arrives and locks to Lila in
the cage she's like look I'm so sorry
I'm Gonna Let You Go he gets some time
release handcuffs like hey just chill
out for a day while I book a flight out
of the country he figures love is better
off without him and leaves her a goodbye
note but just then 40 comes hey you read
books right can you help me write script
earlier Candice I convince him to buy
the movie rights to Beck's book and now
he's hired some goons to lock him in a
hotel room so they can write with no
distractions as part of his process they
also do LSD and hilariously for he
figures it out that Dr Nikki was framed
but not that it was Joe meanwhile love
found Joe's note and his life okay Joe I
don't care what you've done I love you
no matter what let's live happily ever
after so the next morning Joe rushes to
Delilah to discover she's already been
killed and he blacked out last night
doesn't remember if he did it turns out
he did come here last night but 40 also
booty called Candace which gave up this
location now she rushes in and traps Joe
in the cage haha man how do you like it
before she calls the cops she calls love
first because she knows her C and Joe
for who he really is will just hurt him
more but love actually takes Joe's side
and she kills Candace turns out love has
her own psychotic issues and she's
willing to murder to protect the people
she loves she knew from the beginning
that Joe was stalking her but she took
that as evidence that he loved her so
much and she was into it and when he
wanted to leave town so Delilah could
live love couldn't allow that and she
killed Delilah so you'd think these two
are perfect for each other but for Joe
this kind of ruins her he convinces her
to let him out then he's gonna kill her
but she drops a bomb I'm pregnant and
Joe's whole thing is how he was
abandoned by his mom at a young age so
this changes things he's like I'll never
abandon this baby meanwhile Candice told
40 how Joe was the murderer and he went
to talk to Dr Nikki who confirmed it so
40 busts in to save his sister and looks
like this might be the end for Joe but a
shot rings out and Joe's still alive it
was the cop that was following them and
walked in on the situation love is
devastated by her Twin's death so she
and Joe decide to make a fresh start to
move to the suburbs of San Francisco the
Quinn family money sweeps any Loose Ends
under the rug except for Ellie who Joe
doesn't tell everything to but convinces
to go start a new life and still sends
her money sometimes so Joe is set to
live happily ever after with his
wonderful wife who loves him flaws and
all but Joe's not happy he hates
Suburbia and love is not his you anymore
but almost immediately through his fence
he spots his neighbor hello you so in
season three Joe and love are living the
new parent dream but Joe's obsessed with
his neighbor Natalie so he puts on his
baseball cap and starts a stocking she's
married to Tech Guy Matthew angler but
she invites Joe over for a neighborly
glass of wine because she's that unhappy
housewife stereotype ready to have an
affair but Joe actually shuts it down he
really wants to be a good husband to
love but love can tell that his heart's
not in it and she gets suspicious finds
his stalker box she has Natalie a
realtor she'll wear a listing for a new
bakery then down in the basement kills
her with an ax loves like Hey Joe no
more Obsession about other women you
love me only and his love and Joe work
together to cover up this crime it
actually brings them closer together so
when love opens her new bakery in the
basement they build a plastic cage
adjusting case Natalie's disappearance
makes National headlines it's like hey
love we gotta lay low for a bit but when
their son gets to measles because one of
their neighbors is an anti-vaxx idiot a
love can't container self but this guy
survives so their cage gets its first
prisoner and they're hoping they can let
him out if they find some good enough
blackmail on him but turns out their
blackmail is too good and this guy kills
himself loves like well two birds one
stone they plant an ax with his Prince
on it and a suicide note confessing to
kill a Natalie so both cases are wrapped
up now Joe just can't keep away from
books so soon he gets a job at his local
library but he hits it off with his boss
Marianne and before you know it hello
you so Joe gets back up to his usual
stalker Antics and one day during a
sprinkler malfunction these two are
making out but she's like whoa Joe we
can't do this you're married and in fact
Joe's doing everything he can to keep
this one secret so love doesn't murder
her luckily love is distracted with her
own problems trying to open a bakery in
a town where no one eats carbs except
for Theo the neighbor's son home from
college who hits it off with love in
fact he falls in love with her and
though Joe's trying to hide it she can
tell he's distant while Theo gives her
that obsessive attention she craves
meanwhile they've befriended the
neighborhoods queen bee with her alpha
male husband and these two are swingers
invite loving Joe to join him and Love's
down to try if it'll put the spark back
in their marriage but as they get
started Joe is fantasizing about
Marianne and love can absolutely tell
they have a blowout fight where love
explicitly talks about how they murdered
Natalie and it's apparent these two
heard him so this fun night takes a
deadly twist now their cage has some new
residents and this does briefly reignite
that spark meanwhile Natalie's Tech
husband has hacked all the cameras to
investigate her disappearance when Theo
finds out he checks a different angle to
find out Joe was driving the car he
tries to warn love your husband's a
killer but she's like oh you sweet boy
I'm the killer too Joe and Madeline have
fallen madly in love he's like hey I'm
gonna leave my wife and we'll run away
together but she has a daughter she
can't take with her because her
douchebag ex-husband has custody of
course Joe knows how to handle that
problem but he's really bad at killing
people on purpose for Madeline's sake
though he figured it out and now these
two can go live happily ever after his
only obstacle left is love he grabs a
knife just in case but she was one step
ahead of him poisoned the handle and Joe
is paralyzed she calls Madeline over and
is going to make Joe watch while she
kills her but Madeleine brought her
daughter with her and even love wouldn't
do that instead these two have a nice
heart to heart and love realizes it's
Joe who's the problem but now she's
gonna kill him oh Joe is not really
paralyzed yeah he noticed her planting
poison in their Garden so he's decided
to take an antidote and make his own
just in case and now that is how love
dies so Joe does what he does best
writes a suicide note from love
confessing to all the murders and
blaming Suburbia for driving her crazy
but the only way to avoid being
implicated himself is to make it look
like he was her final victim as for
their son Joe realizes he's better off
without them and leaves him with a nice
couple looking to adopt and Theo
survives he'll be okay as well as this
couple who come out even stronger and
Joe Goldberg now with the freedom of
being legally Dead starts over with a
new identity in a new city in fact he's
gone real far this time he heads to
Paris looking for his current you
Marianne will he find her and finally
live happily ever after or will Anew you
take her place we'll find out in you
season 4. if you liked this recap hit
that subscribe button for more of the
best Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]